pour cette demi finale de coupe des
yvelines montini a dû faire avec les
moyens du bord à cause de l'absence de
certains titulaires composaient le 6
types s'est avéré être un vrai puzzle
d'ailleurs dès les premiers points
l'entente des saint quentinois en blanc
est loin d'être parfaite les blocs sont
friables et des espaces restent
désespérément vides en défense la ligne
d'attaqué n'est pas beaucoup plus
efficace trop de ce match ratée de
services imprécis donne des points
gratuits à sartrouville dans le premier
set ils sont rapidement menés 8 depuis
vingt dix et offre la première manche
sur une nouvelle photo service
bis repetita dans le second acte les
joueurs d'abdellatif micheli ne se
révolte pas et encaissent un
indiscutable 25 14 ils n'ont rien pu
faire face à l'expérience sartrouville
oise un adversaire qui comptait dans ses
rangs deux joueurs ayant évolué en
national et qui vient d'obtenir sa
montée en régionale une après avoir
arraché leur maintien lors de la phase
de barrage les joueurs et ni mon temps
semble s en ressources comme épuisés par
leur fin de saison
je m'attendais à une contre performance
mais vraiment pas ce point la pente donc
autant d'enjeux on a essayé de relever
la tête de jouer mais un niveau
d'attitude
non je suis pas montré vraiment une
image de
d'une équipe qui se laisse faire qui
subit alors pas du tout comme ça on a
dit se battre pour un macho qui était
vraiment pas pas facile on a tout donné
ces battues
montrer une image complètement
différente sur cinq six matches s'est
battu pendant cinq six matches mais là
c'était vraiment complètement l'opposé
de ce qu'on est capable de faire en
finale conflent s'impose 2 sets à 1 face
à sartrouville et remporté cette coupe
des îles une version 2013